one of Hollywood's most respected actors
is facing serious allegations People
magazine is reporting that Brad Pitt is
under investigation for child abuse
after he allegedly got verbally abusive
and physical with one of his children
the magazine reports it happen on the
couple's private jet last Wednesday
while some of the other children were
present the magazine also claims Pitt
was inebriated if these claims are true
as far as we know because the alleged
incident happened apparently while they
were on a private plane in the air
therefore it wouldn't fall under the
jurisdiction of LAPD but instead it
would fall under the jurisdiction of the
FBI this morning we confirmed that Brad
and Angie's jet did make a landing that
day in Minnesota people claimed that the
LA Department of Children and Family
Services is conducting the investigation
the agency told us quote we have very
strict confidentiality laws and the laws
do not allow us to confirm or deny the
subjects of our investigations
if Child Services is indeed
investigating what would likely happen
to the children they'd probably be
interviewed by caseworkers also the
parents would probably be interviewed by
caseworkers it's likely the caseworkers
would visit their house and see what the
in kind of environment they were living
in the magazine also cites another
source that says Pitt is denying the
abuse claims the timeline of all this is
pretty interesting
before this alleged incident Brad and
Angelina seemed like a solid couple the
alleged abuse on the jet reportedly took
place September 14 in her divorce filing
Angelina declares the following day
September 15th as their date of
separation the claims are surprising
because Brad always lit up on the red
carpet when we asked about his kids you
know we want to make it a family affair
and have the kids running in and out of
said it was morning as usual playing
with the kids and getting breakfast and
yeah trying to get trying to get ready
so we have a 10 11 12 15 year old and
two twins that are eight years old if
this does happen and if caseworkers do
have to interview the children this can
definitely be a very traumatic
experience for them
[Music]